- So your baking show nailed it,
it was nominated for an Emmy, right?
- Yes, yes, yes,
- [Kelly] That's crazy!
(audience claps and cheers)
- Thank you!
Thank you, we did lose.
We lost to RuPaul's Drag
Race which I get it.
It's my favorite show.
I truly love it.
- It's hilarious.
- [Nicole] It's so good.
- Yeah, did you get to meet anybody cool?
Have you ever been to the Emmys before?
- No, I've never been to the Emmys.
- I've only been once, and I felt like
which one of these is not like the other.
- [Nicole] Wait, only one time?
- [Kelly] Why the hell
would I be at the Emmys?
(audience cheers)
- Beause you're all of our American Idol.
- No, I just mean, like now
I have a tv show, but before,
you know singers don't
generally just show up.
- Oh, I guess so, well,
it was my first Emmys.
It was very glamorous.
I loved it.
There's just famous
people very close to you
which is like a real delight.
- Yeah, well when they're a delight.
- Well yes, but they're all.
Well, they're walking
around with publicists,
so they don't have time
to be mean, you know, but
(audience laughs)
I saw Viola Davis, and I love Viola Davis.
- Me too
- I also saw
her on a plane recently, and I was like,
I need to talk to her.
But then I was like, she's
living her life don't do it.
So, I didn't do it, but then at the Emmys,
I was like, "This is a work event,
"I can talk to whoever I want!"
- [Kelly] It is a work event.
- I just picture two
people on your shoulders
just talkin' to you.
(all laugh)
- Good cop, bad cop.
- So I went up to her, and I
was like, "I am bothering you,
"but I need you to know I love you."
And she truly was like
half eating a hamburger
and was like, "Mmhm."
- Oh, my gosh.
- [Nicole] She was very sweet.
- That's awesome, yeah, no, she's amazing.
I'm a big fan of hers.
Have you fanned out over anybody before?
- Stevie Wonder
- [Kelly] Well
(audience claps)
- I recently, well, a couple years ago,
I got the chance to work with him.
He worked on one of my songs.
Went into his studio where
he actually can function
in the entire studio, walk
around with nobody's help.
He knows exactly where everything is.
And every time he comes
across to you, he be like,
"Nice to see you Jason, nice to see you."
I'm like Stevie, "Stop, stop,
with the nice to see you."
(audience laughs)
- You're hilarious.
That's awesome though he
knows where everything is.
That's awesome.
It must be like a
comfortable place for him.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean,
he's in there every day.
- You got to work with Stevie
Wonder, that's amazing!
- That's cool.
(audience claps)
- There is an interesting story
about your drivers license
which I kind of connect to,
but I wanna hear yours, it's amazing.
- Okay, so I bought this big wig
from a drag queen wig maker.
- [Kelly] As we do.
- You know, I was truly feeling myself.
I was like,
the bigger the wig the closer to God.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- So truly, that's how I walked
through the Glendale DMV,
and everyone was like, "What is it?"
(all laugh)
And then in my Netflix special,
currently streaming on Netflix,
I have a joke about
why is your weight on
your drivers license.
Who's gonna question it?
Like my drivers license
use to say 150 pounds,
and I wrote it down,
and the lady truly just
like squinted at me.
(audience laughs)
And I was like, I dare you.
I dare you to say something.
She didn't say anything, so I was like
the next time I get it renewed
I'll put 90 pounds, so I put
- You legit have 90 pounds?
- My drivers license says 90 pounds.
(all laugh)
- That's the greatest.
Like has anyone seen it?
Like when you show people,
has anyone said anything?
- Nobody has clocked it, but
I'm waiting for someone to be,
"Where, in your leg?"
(all laugh)
I can't wait.
I'm gonna put like two
pounds the next time.